In this problem, we were tasked with figuring out how much work 65 kg Andy
has to do to climb this flight of stairs that's 6 m tall.
Let's think about what's going on here in terms of energy.
Andy starts and ends with no kinetic energy,
so none of his net work is going to contribute towards kinetic energy,
but because Andy ends at a higher height than he started,
that means he has more gravitational potential energy up here
than he did down here.
This just means that the net work done by Andy is equal to the change in his potential energy.
This, of course, is just equal to the final potential energy minus the original potential energy.
If we choose potential energy to be 0 at the bottom of the stairs,
we can say that the original potential energy--when he's at the bottom of the stairs--
is equal to 0.
This leave just the final potential energy term,
which we know is equal to mg times the final height.
Plugging in all my values here, I find that Andy has to do 3900 J of work
to climb this 6 m flight of stairs. Great job.